الجو أسود قاتم خارج
كنيسة ساوث كارولينا على أهبة الاستعداد، العشرات
من ضباط إنفاذ القانون المسلحين
اليوم يمسكون
بالكلاب المقاتلة خلفهم CU أنا
قلق بالتأكيد، أنا حريص دائمًا على رؤية
الكلاب التي نركبها جنبًا إلى جنب مع
المدعي الفيدرالي الذي يشرف  القضية الجنائية
مفجعة، أشعر
بالعاطفة الشديدة بسبب الطريقة التي أصبح بها قتال الكلاب الشرس
أكثر وضوحًا في
وثائق المحكمة، الكلاب التي تم
قتالها قد تكون بها ندوب وجروح
ووجوه منتفخة أو آذان مشوهة، في إحدى
القضايا يقول المدعي العام إن المالك قتل كلبه
شنقها وعثرت السلطات على هذه
الأداة الغريبة المصنوعة من كابلات التوصيل التي
يُزعم أنها استخدمت لصعق الكلاب بالكهرباء
داخل منزل أحد
موظفي البنتاغون. يُظهر دليل الفيديو الحصري لشبكة CNN
من قضية قريبة
كلبين يستعدان
لمحاربة هذه الرياضة غير القانونية وقد أثارت
الاهتمام الفيدرالي العام الماضي
أوقفت ما يقرب من 400 كلب من
عصابات القتال المشتبه بها أكثر من أي
عام آخر منذ عام 2007 على الأقل وفقًا
لمراجعة شبكة سي إن إن للمصادرات المدنية،
أخبرتني جين تايلور أنها كانت
مدعية عامة لمكافحة المخدرات طوال حياتها حتى رأت لأول مرة
الإصابات على الكلاب المقاتلة، وكانت لدي
قضية حيث  لقد قمنا بالتنصت على المكالمات الهاتفية
وكنا نستمع إلى مكالمات
الأفراد المتورطين في المخدرات وبدأنا
نسمع الكثير من سيشن عن
الكلاب
وقتال الكلاب، وصلنا إلى أول
منزل من بين خمسة منازل، ما نوع الأشياء التي
تبحث عنها؟  عندما تدخل عقارًا،
فإنني أبحث عن حالة
الكلاب نفسها، وأبحث عن أي نوع
من التندب وأي جروح جديدة، ثم
أبحث أيضًا عما سأسميه
أدوات قتال الكلاب مثل هذه
المطاحن لتكوين الكلب  أقوى
وأسرع وما يسمى بأعمدة الربيع
حيث تستخدم الكلاب للقفز للأعلى والتشبث بها من
المفترض أن تقوي
فكيها. ويقول
الخبراء إن الكلاب غالبًا ما يتم ربطها
بسلاسل ثقيلة وأطواق مثقلة
لزيادة قوتها، ويقوم بعض
مصارعي الكلاب بحقن حيواناتهم بها.  المخدرات
أو الفيتامينات لزيادة العدوان
وقبل قتال كبير، يتم تجويع بعض الكلاب المقاتلة
لإبقائها في
فئة وزنها مثل الملاكم المختبئ في هذه
المنطقة المشجرة، ويعثر العملاء الفيدراليون على
أول ما يقرب من 120 قطعة من الحفرة التي سيتم
الاستيلاء عليها وما الذي سيتحول  من المتوقع أن تكون
ثاني أكبر عملية
مصادرة للكلاب المقاتلة في ولاية كارولينا الجنوبية في يوم واحد، ويقول
المحققون إنه تم تصويرهم
وتحميلهم في مقطورات للحصول على الرعاية الطبية
والمأوى، وعندما نذهب إلى عقار،
فإنهم سيهزون ذيلهم لأنه
لم يكن لديهم أي منها  التفاعل أعني
التفاعل الودي الرائد فرانك أونيل
مع قسم إنفاذ القانون في ولاية كارولينا الجنوبية، لقد
تعرضوا للإيذاء إما
من قبل المالك أو من قبل كلب مقاتل، وهذا ما
ينفطر قلبك، فالناس
يكسبون الكثير من المال من هذا الأمر
برأيي حتى  إن الدولار كثير جدًا بحيث لا يمكن جني
الأموال من هذا، وهناك
طرق كثيرة للحصول على أموال وفقًا
لوثائق المحكمة في ولاية كارولينا الجنوبية.
دفع المشاركون
200 ألف دولار لتقاتل حيواناتهم
ضد كلب كبير، وفاز كلب مقاتل آخر
بأكثر من
50 ألف دولار من مالك الكلب.  يمكن للكلب البطل أن
يجني المزيد من المال من رسوم تربية البحارة والجراء،
وكثير منهم من
تجار المخدرات لأنه يتعين عليهم تمويل
المقامرة بهذه الكلاب وهذه الكلاب
باهظة الثمن، وسيكون لديهم
أسلحة، وإذا كان لدينا بالفعل
القبض على  من المحتمل أننا
سنلقي القبض عليهم في
ساحة أخرى داخل هذا المنزل، حيث عثر الضباط على
عدة أسلحة رفض صاحب المنزل
التحدث مع
عملاء CNN الفيدراليين، وحزموا أمتعتهم وتوجهوا إلى
المنزل التالي الذي يبعد حوالي 20 دقيقة،
ويقولون إن هناك حوالي 12 كلبًا.
أصبح قتال الكلاب جناية على
المستوى الفيدرالي في عام 2007، حيث إن الحد الأقصى للعقوبة التي
يمكن أن يواجهها المشتبه به هو 5 سنوات في
السجن الفيدرالي. وفي الوقت نفسه، بالنسبة للحيوانات،
يقول الخبراء إن بعض الكلاب عدوانية للغاية بحيث لا يمكن
إعادة تأهيلها، ولكن يمكن تبني البعض الآخر
والحصول على فرصة ثانية  الحياة إيزابيل
روزاليز سي إن إن
أتلانتا